yeah behave yourself don't do that and
you're saying you're from acting yeah
yeah listen you need to stop that
attitude yeah what the [__]
happened brothers and sisters just
imagine for a second that you give £10
in donation and that £10 is used to buy
food or bricks or whatever to help the
people in Gaza but then just imagine
this amazing de that you want to do but
we turn it into a moneymaking machine
how the W is exactly that they take your
money and the money that we are going to
put in in this W this building and every
single time the money generated from
that W that building is going to go to
our Palestinian brothers and sisters for
the next 20 30 40 50 60 100 150 years
and this will be a form of
true I myself will be donating for that
inshah click the link below and donate
may Allah subhana bless and preserve you
guys brothers and sisters and dear
friends so this Punk who was put to
sleep by a Muslim Brother May bless his
hands and preserve him inallah for uh
choking him out which which is to to
deescalate the situation you know
because there's a threat in front of him
uh you know this baldheaded clown he got
put to sleep inshallah uh we're going to
watch that video but before we do
brothers and sisters we need to
understand something yeah this man tried
to abuse a Muslim woman and he realized
what time is and most time they target
Muslim women because they know what
would happen to them if they tried on
Muslim men well these days can we even
say that because a lot of Muslim men
sadly are not doing much they are not
active and this has Ripple effects and
consequences because you're not just
going to lose your manhood and and
you're not in the sense but you are also
going to probably lose your wife I'll
come to why but let's first watch this
video inallah
[Music]
see you people like you bro you need to
behave yourself no sit down sit down sit
down sit down sit down no no no no no
Noah what you say about Muslims now I
respect them you respect them now yeah
yeah behave yourself don't do that and
you're saying you're from acting yeah
yeah listen you need to stop that
attitude yeah what the [__] happened
yeah you got up to bed that's what
happened why
you so guys what you saw there Subhan
Allah as you can see the brother was
obviously in a bit of an exchange back
and forth Etc I think gave him a left
jab and then after that he just put him
in a choke and put him to sleep and I'll
be honest with you I mean maybe I would
have done something else but he puts him
on the floor and makes sure that you
know the blood circulates back to his
flipping little brain um and he
obviously wakes up comes to his senses
and says oh you know he was nether going
to kill me this Etc yeah you're lucky
you know uh but one thing I want to
mention brothers and sisters especially
to Brothers okay you need to understand
it is your duty it is your duty to
protect and provide for your wife it is
your duty that's given to you by Allah
subhana tala in Surah verse 34 so you
need to make sure that you do that you
need to be active don't be someone who's
sitting because let me tell you
something this will hit you so hard you
will not forget for the rest of your
life if you out with your wife and some
idiot tries something and you don't even
know how to throw a punch or even
attempt to you are going to lose in many
ways number one is the ISA of being a
Muslim Islam yes you're a Muslim man
over there cannot even do anything let
alone run away or whatever for that
matter not that we're saying there's
anything wrong if there's somebody who's
got a knife Etc again yes we know the of
the Prophet Muhammad PE the one who
defends his wealth is like someone who
dies as a Marty but the point is that
we're seeing so forget a knife if this
guy is squaring up to you which he did
you saw and don't get fooled by the size
how big his shoulders it means nothing
it means zero so the the thing is that's
number one number two you're going to
lose yourself why because imagine that
happens to you in front of your wife how
you going to feel after how you going to
feel after HH number three women are
hypergamous by Nature how do you think
your wife's going to view you after that
do you think she's going to be like this
is a man that I like being around he's
going to protect me I'm going to feel
secure no she's hypergamous by Nature
this can even cause like this might
sound extreme man I'm telling you very
clearly this might even cause her to
slowly drift away from you and not only
that not to even lower a gaze and be
like you know what actually that brother
there m he looks Hench you know maybe he
can protect me I'm telling you this this
is this is not blameworthy you need to
understand Allah has enabled a man to
always be in striving of to Excellence
whatever it is in combat knowledge
whatever it is for that matter you have
to be that a woman looks for that the
woman looks for the best version of
yourself that's how they created so you
need to understand that in real life
this could have gone any other way so
our brother I don't know if it was his
woman folks it doesn't matter this
matter whoever it was done toward Subhan
Allah he came and put the man sleep and
what did the man say as he as he got
he's on the floor what's saying yeah I
respect Muslim woman now yeah of course
you respect Muslim woman nor only that I
believe this man start reading the Quran
after this I believe he thought to
himself you know what I respect this
religion yeah he probably may Allah
guide him may Allah guide him yeah aldah
he came to guide us before he died with
that choke so Brothers specifically
please please wake up get up and do
something boxing Brazilian jiujitsu
wrestling whatever it is get up from
your backside you have you weight
everywhere you have please please w i i
gen believe this look and it's something
and I'm not seeing this from a place
below just cuz I do Sports I don't like
I don't like boxing I don't like
bodybuilding I don't like having ice
Buffs I don't like going jogging I don't
like my new routine I don't like it but
who said you have to like it go out your
way be uncomfortable get used to being
uncomfortable get used to pain because
as men we have so many responsibilities
on our shoulders and we need to teach
the next generation of men this very
thing and it is a part of Islam
inshallah that's all I want to say
inallah um and I ask Allah to guide this
man and hope he's Chang his ways and
that brother who did this may Allah
bless and preserve him
and make his hand stronger for more men
like these clowns